Now looking at the code we just wrote, what we really want to do is change this
from querying the value of KEY.W to move-up, which is the actual game
information we care about. In order to do that, we need to bind keys to events
in our game engine like so. In order to enable this functionality, what you're
going to need to do is to modify the input manager class just a tad bit. First
thing, what you'll need to do is actually add a bind function. Now the bind
function will need to take the key value, and attach it to the action, via the
bindings dictionary value that we placed up here. Secondly, you'll actually
have to modify your onKeyDown and KeyUp events, such that the keyCode actually
modifies the state in the array. Now, we've left these two functions as
exercises for you to figure out. Good luck.